Il y a deux semaines, je vous avais proposé de me poser vos questions pour une petite FAQ d'anniversaire
Nous te souhaitons un joyeux anniversaire
Eh ouais DTC a un an passé et comme à chaque fois, vous avez répondu présent, c'est pour ça que je vous aime.
Et comme à chaque fois, ça été une véritable torture de devoir faire le tri parmi vos question, mais bon dans la vie, il faut faire des choix
alors oui, avant de commencer, vous été très nombreuses et nombreux
à me poser des questions auxquelles j'ai déjà répondu
dans ma première FAQ, celle de  l'année dernière
Bon alors je vous juge pas hein, c'est vrai que s'était déjà depuis un petit momment
mais pour ne pas ralentir ceux qui suivent, ce que je vous propose
c'est que je vous remet le lien de la première FAQ dans la description
et vous irez y jeter un petit coup d’œil après
mais commençons sans plus attendre
Pourquoi avoir voulu faire DTC  ? Est-ce que c'est pour également t'améliorer dans le domaine scientifique ?
Ou juste pour divertir et instruire?
Alors j'ai déjà répondu à la partie pourquoi, mais pour le reste bah j'ai envie que les gens s'amusent, rigolent
et qu'ils repartent en ayant appris une ou deux choses,
voir en ayant envie d'en apprendre un petit peu plus ailleurs si possible voilà
Es-tu en couple ?
*musique triste*
Pourquoi n'as-tu pas fait de "vlog" sur la Vidéo City Paris ?
Eh bah j'suis pas sur que ce genre de vlog ça ait vraiment sa place sur DTC
du coup peut-être qu'il faudrait que j'ouvre une chaîne secondaire
je sais pas dites moi ce que vous en penser dans les commentaires vidéo.
À qui appartient le squelette derrière toi ?
Lui, c'est Lémy, il s'appelle Lémy et il appartient à personne
c'est un membre de la grande famille de DTC comme nous tous
Avec l'aide d'associations, tu pourrais aller dans des pays du tiers monde faire de l'humanitaire
alors oui, je pourrais et franchement si j'ai l'opportunité, j'hésiterai pas une seconde
Quel est ton fromage préféré ?
C'est le gorgonzola y mascarpone, la légende raconte, qu'on peut choper du cholestérol rien qu'en le regardant
Raconte nous ta plus grosse honte en milieu médical
alors, il y en a vraiment beaucoup et elles sont pas toutes racontables
bon, il y a bien cette nuit, quand je travaillais en réanimation
où j'avais vidé un tube de pommade entier dans le slip d'un collègue
et pendant qu'il était en train de s'essuyer, moi, je rigolais comme une baleine
quand j'ai croisé le regard de la seule patiente consciente du service
Je vous jure qu'elle me jugeait très fort à travers la vitre.
Est-ce-que tu vas changer ton intro de vidéo ?
Mon générique ? alors vraiment non, j'y pense pas du tout parce que moi je l'aime beaucoup
je sais pas vous, mais moi je l'aime beaucoup donc non
Comment tes parents ont réagi à la carrière que toi et ton frère ont choisi de prendre en l'occurrence YouTube?
Nos parents sont morts
Est-ce-que tu penses dans le futur, t'installer dans un vrai décor pour faire tes vidéos ?
alors, j'ai eu pas mal de questions sur ce sujet
un vrai décor non, je pense pas enfin pas tout de suite en tout cas, parce que le fond vert ça permet quand même
pas mal de petites fantaisies
D'où vient le décor que tu utilises sur ton fond vert ?
Ah vous voyez, il fascine vraiment ce décor hein, et ben c'est  Cyprien qui l'a réalisé avec ses petits doigts gracieux.
À la base tu voulais être infirmier ou t'aurais voulu être médecin ?
Non j'ai jamais pensé être médecin, vraiment infirmier, ça m'allait très bien
Y a que Romain derrière la caméra ?
À non non pas du tout derrière, il y a tout une équipe qui travaille extrêmement dur
Non, je déconne, on est juste deux
À quel âge, a tu fais ta première ?
Mmh, 14, à 14 mois, j'ai pris ma première cuite à 14 mois
Non c'est vrai, vous pouvez chercher sur google si vous ne me croyez pas
Feras-tu une sextape avec Romain ?
Ok.
Romain ?
Mmh non, non en fait non.
Ça te fais quoi la barbe et les cheveux gris ?
On s'en bat les couilles, On s'en bat les couilles, On s'en bat les couilles  hunhunhunhun
je m'en bats pas les couilles de ta question, je m'en bats les couilles d'avoir les cheveux gris, voilà
Comment se porte Cyril ?
Alors, beaucoup trop bien à mon goût, on va avoir l'occasion d'en reparler extrêmement vite
As-tu des enfants ?
J'ai deux enfants : Milio et Lena et vous savez quoi ? eh bah ils ont tous les deux des chaînes You Tube
eh ouais, c'est toute la famille, d'ailleurs, je les embrasse
Une raclette ?
ton groupe du moment ? Ultra Vomit parce que leur dernier album est un bijou
et le premier single de Waxx qui va aussi sortir un album
Es-tu un OVNI ?
Oui, on m'appel l'OVNI, non, je déconne, j'suis un Terrien tout ce qu'il y a de plus normal
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, merci pour toutes vos questions, il y en a eu tellement
qu'on va faire une deuxième partie à cette FAQ, donc à très bientôt et d'ici là mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous bien